[Music]
the people of wah dwell in the middle of
the ocean on the mountainous Islands
southeast of the prefecture of Tai Fang
they formerly comprised more than 100
communities during the Han Dynasty wah
envoy's appeared at the court today 30
of their communities maintained
intercourse with us through envoy's and
scribes the land of wah is worn and mild
in winter as in summer the people live
on raw vegetables and go about
barefooted they have or live in houses
father and mother elder and younger
sleep separately they smear their bodies
with pink and Scarlets just as the
Chinese use powder they serve food on
bamboo and wooden trays helping
themselves with their fingers when a
person dies they prepare a single coffin
without an outer one they cover the
graves with earth to make a mound when
death occurs mourning is observed for
more than 10 days during which period
they do not eat meat the head mourners
wail and lament while friends sing dance
and drink liquor when the funeral is
over all members of the family go into
the water to cleanse themselves in a
bath of purification when they go on
voyages across the sea to visit China
they always select a man who does not
comb his hair does not rid himself of
fleas
lets his clothing get as dirty as it
will does not eat meat and does not live
with women this man behaves like mourner
and is known as the morning keeper when
the voyage meets with good fortune they
all lavish on him slaves and other
valuables in case there is a disease or
mishap they kill him saying that he was
not scrupulous in observing the taboo
Jews
whenever they undertake an enterprise or
a journey and discussion arises they
bake bones and divine in order to tell
whether fortune will be good or bad
first they announce the object of
divination using the same manner of
speech as in tortoiseshell divination
they then examine the cracks made by the
fire and tell what is to come to pass in
their meetings and in their deportment
there is no distinction between father
and son or between men and women they
are fond of liquor in their worship men
of importance simply clap their hands
instead of kneeling or bowing the people
live long some to 100 and others to 80
or 90 years ordinarily men of importance
have four or five wives the lesser ones
two or three women are not loose in
morals or jealous there is no theft and
litigation is infrequent in case of
violation of law the light offender
loses his wife and children by
confiscation as for the grave offender
the members of his household and also
his kinsmen are exterminated there are
class distinctions among the people and
some men are vassals of others taxes are
collected there are granaries as well as
markets in each province where
necessaries are exchanged under the
supervision of the war officials when
the lowly meat men of importance on the
road they stop and withdraw to the
roadside in conveying messages to them
or addressing them they either squat or
kneel with both hands on the ground this
is the way they show respect when
responding they say our which
corresponds to the affirmative yes the
country formerly had a man as a ruler
for some 70 or 80 years after that there
were
disturbances and warfare thereupon the
people agreed upon a woman for their
ruler
her name was perm echo she occupied
herself with magic and sorcery
bewitching the people though mature in
age she remained unmarried she had a
younger brother who assisted her in
ruling the country after she became the
ruler there were a few who saw her she
had 1,000 women as attendants but only
one man he served her food and drink and
acted as a medium of communication she
resided in the palace surrounded by
hours and stockades with armed guards in
a state of constant vigilance in the
sixth month of the second year of Ching
Chu the queen of wasent the grand ena
shown me and others to visit the
prefecture where they requested
permission to proceed to the empress
court with tribute the governor Liu Xie
dispatched an official to accompany the
party to the capital in answer to the
queen of hua need act of the Emperor
issued in the 12th month of the same
year said as follows
here in we address P Miko queen of Hwa
whom we now officially call a friend of
way the governor of Tai Fang Lucia has
sent a messenger to accompany your
vassal Nashawn me and his lieutenant Xiu
Shi gory they have arrived here with
your tribute consisting of four male
slaves and six female slaves together
with two pieces of cloth with designs
each 20 feet in length you live very far
away across the sea yet you have sent an
embassy with tribute your loyalty and
filial piety
we appreciate exceedingly we confer upon
you therefore the title queen of Hwa
friendly to weigh together with the
decoration of the gold seal with purple
ribbon the latter properly encased is to
be sent to you through the governor we
expect you oh queen to rule your people
in peace and to endeavor to be devoted
and obedient when pineco passed away a
great mound was raised more than a
hundred paces in diameter over a hundred
male and female attendants followed her
to the grave then a king was placed on
the throne but the people would not obey
Him assassination and murder followed
more than 1,000 were thus slain a
relative of the miko named AO a girl of
13 was then made queen and order was
restored Chang the Chinese ambassador
issued a proclamation to the effect that
IO was the ruler then AO sent a
delegation of 20 under the Grandy yosaku
general of the imperial guard to
accompany Chang home to China the
delegation visited the capital and
presented 30 male and female slaves it
also offered to the court 5000 white
gems and two pieces of carved Jade as
well as 20 pieces of brocade of various
designs
[Music]
you
[Music]